Speaker 1: Let's get to our live calls today.
The most important people for the show are the
viewers and the listeners. Without you, I'm a
guy in a room talking to no one and it's sad.
So we take calls via discord at David Pakman
dot com slash discord and let's see what is
on people's minds. Let's start today with
is it Desmond or Dez? Move from Birmingham.
Speaker 4: Yeah. It's Guzman.
Speaker 1:
Desmond, what's going on today?
Speaker 4: Hey, I'm chillin,
man. Good. Hey. So my question for you was, it
seems to be that there is a trend to undermine
American democracy by the right, as well as
things like encouraging general political
violence. Do you think that this is a trend that
will continue into the future, or do you think
that this is something that will slow down?
Speaker 1: It will continue unless there is
something that stops it and
says that it's unacceptable.
And that is a number of different works.
Speaker 4: I'm sorry. You think like worsen
or maybe like pretty much the same it is now.
Speaker 1: I think it will almost certainly
worsen. Barack Obama at a speech earlier this week
in Nevada, made this point, and I think he made it
astutely and accurately, which is when you have
one side that generically will condemn violence
when there is violence, but they will coddle and
inspire and allude to it being an acceptable form
of political speech. And then their followers
start to do the violence in small scale stuff,
like an individual attack on Paul Pelosi and
in large scale stuff like the January six Trump
riots. And yes, the Trump rioters are slowly being
held accountable as their cases are adjudicated,
but those who inspired that event have not been
held accountable. Why on earth would they stop to
the extent that they believe it benefits them?
And it's good to keep the other side scared,
which clearly they believe something
has to happen to get them to stop.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Speaker 4: And thanks for having me. My question.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. You think
things are okay in Alabama?
Speaker 4: I mean, I'm in Birmingham, so
it's kind of like a blue bubble surrounded
in a sea of red. So it's a little different
here compared to the rest of the state. So I
can't really speak for the more rural areas,
but we're we're chillin in Birmingham. It's
nothing too out of the ordinary right now.
Speaker 1: You can get like a good you
can get a good cappuccino in Birmingham.
Speaker 4: Yeah. It's nothing too out of
the ordinary. It's kind of like a it's not like a
huge city or anything comparable to like Atlanta,
everything. But it's pretty normal.
There's like, you know, I mean,
there's, like, nothing too odd going on.
Speaker 1: I would love to visit someday.
Speaker 2: It would be cool to see Iran.
Speaker 1: All
right, Desmond, you from Birmingham.
Appreciate the call very much. Thank you.